In some cases, they're the total access
point. Like if there is a physical piece
of paper, if there is a computer
theoretically left at a airport or
something like that, that is a human
element. But at the same time, yes, you
can manipulate a person to give up
passwords, click on a fishing message or
whatever.
And when you ask me where does the human
element come in and where this sounds
like everybody should be thinking this,
but to me the human element is a tactic
within a larger strategy
where yes, a user can click on a fishing
message and give away credentials,
download malware, whatever, but the user
is just clicking. The user is not
installing malware. the user is not
transmitting their credentials across a
network. The user frankly even
fundamentally didn't put the email
message in their inbox
system did. And so when you ask me how
do you address the human problem we have
to look at the human yes as a I'd call
it the proximity
of the problem but it's just the
proximity of the problem not the cause
of the problem.
>> [music]
>> Ira Winkler, thank you so much for
joining me at another series of the
human zero day. I am super excited to
have a really great and thoughtful
conversation with you. Thank you for
being here.
>> Oh, thanks for having me. I always
appreciate a reason to pontificate about
this stuff.
Well, we're we're going to talk about
something that I think is super
interesting and super important and
coincidentally it's something that you
really are a deep expert in. Uh we're
going to talk about, you know, humans
and and the role that humans play in
security systems and the role that
humans play in the context of of
vulnerabilities
to uh to security systems. And so, Ira,
um, I'd really love to hear in your
words your journey because you've done
so much from the NSA to HP to working
with multitude of companies to to
Walmart and so you've really seen it all
and done it all really, written books
about this stuff. But, you know, even
before you walk me through your journey,
Ira tell me a little bit about how you
got into cyber security in the first
place.
I mean it was by default like you know
it's kind of part of my journey. When I
was in college I was a psychology major
and luckily I took a random test and it
was a test for NSA and they said I had
really good computer aptitude and I
hated computers and I wanted nothing to
do with it. And they're like okay how
about crypt analysis where you do
puzzles? I'm like I'm not looking at
ones and zeros all day. And I took a job
as an intelligence analyst at NSA. And
then what happened was I hated that job
royally and I was surrounded by
computers. And then I found out that the
people in the computer intern program
got paid more than I did. So I reapplied
for the computer intern program. And
then I was my first assignment was doing
crypt analysis. you know, basically
using supercomputers to break machine
cryptography.
And you could argue that's a cyber
security role. Then I did other things
like including software testing, which
you could arguably say that's a cyber
security role. Then I did deployment,
you know, support to military operations
and a few other things. But you know
then if you want to say I mean I guess
when I started working at NSA even when
I was an intelligence analyst I was out
doing traffic analysis to figure out
patterns in the traffic and you could
argue that's almost a cyber security
role too but where I got into commercial
cyber security I left NSA after a while
and I was working at a government
contractor and they said instead of
going into the Pentagon today can you
make a few phone calls and 3 days later
I had control over one of the world's
largest investment banks and
lo and behold that was cyber security
um
>> wow
>> it was so I mean I wrote a paper about
it was called the seinal work in social
engineering and I had to look up what
seinal meant and what social engineering
meant I joke so that's kind of how I got
my start and it you know let's face it
it's a rush to take over a bank and
steal a billion dollars as I joke But
you know after that I kind of really
keyed in on that. So in that context
social engineering this is a really
really big and core pillar to
>> to what this series is about. Uh social
engineering obviously is a core
cornerstone
to human vulnerabilities in zero days.
What is social engineering in your
perspective? I mean, social engineering
at a high level is the manipulation of
people to do things they wouldn't
otherwise do or shouldn't do.
>> And so basically, it's the art of
manipulating people.
>> Mhm.
>> And that that's what I call it at a high
level. Too many people want to refer to
it as fishing, which is the old, you
know, it started out, you know,
primarily in cyber security is phone
calls to get people to give up
information.
You know, in other ways, you know, I
started I got my reputation by doing
what people would refer to as black bag
operations
where when people started, you know,
coming to me like after I wrote that
paper, I mentioned, you know, that
people came to me, it's like, Ira, can
you go undercover in my company and rob
us blind? I'm like, yeah, sure. Did I
have any clue what I was doing? No. But
um you know I used some of the human
intelligence training that I got while I
was at NSA and um you know read up and
did a bunch of other stuff to prepare
myself and essentially I just would walk
around and talk people into giving me
information.
So in the context of
you know security
traditionally I think people think of
cyber security and they immediately
their mind immediately goes to
not not just the matrix and zeros and
ones on the screen but they go to
machine protection and and today we hear
all the time about cloud security and
data security and and different kind
application security right where is this
human element coming in to this world of
cyber security. What is its role?
>> So the human element and this is where I
drive awareness professionals a little
crazy you know cuz I think fundamentally
the human element is a piece of cyber
security
and the fact of the matter is that why
do people target the human? The human is
an access point for information or
computer access.
And the bizarre part is that they are
only I mean in some cases they're the
total access point like if there is a
physical piece of paper if there is a
computer theoretically left at a airport
or something like that that is a human
element. But at the same time, yes, you
can manipulate a person to give up
passwords, click on a fishing message or
whatever.
And when you ask me where does the human
element come in and where this sounds
like everybody should be thinking this,
but to me the human element is a tactic
within a larger strategy
where yes, a user can click on a fishing
message and give away credentials,
download malware, whatever, but the user
is just clicking. The user is not
installing malware. the user is not
transmitting their credentials across a
network. The user frankly even
fundamentally didn't put the email
message in their inbox
system did. And so when you ask me how
do you address the human problem? We
have to look at the human yes as a I'd
call it the proximity
of the problem but it's just the
proximity of the problem not the cause
of the problem. And that's why I say
when people focus on awareness they're
focusing on what they should consider a
tactic. But unfortunately most people
consider awareness the strategy for
dealing with the human element of cyber
security when the strategy should be hey
the human is the proximity
but there's a whole bunch of technology
architecture
process that should all be layered
around the user around the proximity
and so I'll leave it at that for now
>> and it but it does sound to me like you
you do believe that's
>> that awareness should have some role in
it or do you believe that it's that it's
mainly the perimeter that needs to be
looked at and that awareness is not
where the focus should be?
>> No, I believe awaren every element
throughout each tactic has a role in
risk reduction.
>> Yes.
>> So for example, a tactic is a secure
email gateway.
>> A tactic is awareness. each one of them
can reduce the risk at each point in the
chain.
>> Right? And you have to understand that a
user clicking on a fishing message that
is not the entirety of the incident.
The entirety of the incident is the bad
guy having access on the internet to
botn nets that can send fishing
messages. Right? It includes the lack of
demark on the perimeter for example to
let it through. It includes a secure
email gateway failing. It includes the
anti-malware on the computer the user is
failing. It includes after a user action
not stopping the action by technology.
And so
we need to look at this from start to
finish as a holistic issue not as again
a point issue. And to that point, cuz
you asked about awareness, I mean, I
wrote security awareness for dummies. I
wrote you can stop stupid. Awareness is
a critical risk reduction tool because
fundamentally, like I said, every point,
every point in this whole chain will
fail. Everybody's like, "Oh, those
users, no matter what they do, they
click." I'm like, "Those secure email
gateways, no matter what you do, they'll
let fishing messages through." In order
for a fishing message to go through, a
secure email gateway had to fail. If a
user fails, a whole layers of technology
have failed. But that doesn't mean that
we shouldn't have risk reduction
afterwards as well. But the user, yes,
the security ML gateway, the demark, all
this other stuff would have had to fail.
And if we can get the failure rate of a
human from 20% down to 4% as an example,
we can roughly reduce the number of
incidents by five. You know if you know
we can reduce the number of incidents
roughly by you know 80%.
>> Right?
>> And much like a security mill gateway
will reduce incidents by 99.9%.
Awareness has its own point of risk
reduction in the chain.
>> So what it sounds to me if I'm if I'm
looking at what you just said which is I
think incredibly important here. you're
you're saying I'm seeing that a lot of
times people you know security teams are
conflating
tactics with strategy in the context of
human security that
>> exactly
>> you know every other discipline looks at
things as a strategy for example
accounting
humans will fail in the subject of
accounting you know and what I mean by
that is some human will go ahead and
misenter data. Some human might go ahead
and try to steal money.
Accounting doesn't care for care about
why there's an error along the way. They
care about the discrepancies and finding
and correcting the discrepancies and
then going ahead and investigating why
it happened. Cuz in the human aspects,
we also have to consider that in some
cases a human might be malicious. In
some cases, a human is intentional on
bypassing security, possibly for good
reasons.
But, you know, everybody's like, "Oh,
the user didn't do exactly what we told
them to. So, bad user more awareness."
You know, we have to look at why
awareness is not going to help a
malicious user. Awareness is not going
to help a user who can't do their job
because of security
processes,
>> you know. Absolutely.
>> Awareness needs to be a tactic within
again a larger strategy. And I should h
I should actually say good awareness is
a tactic otherwise I mean there are so
many awareness programs that are poorly
implemented and pretty useless.
So let's dive a little bit into
awareness and then I want to wrap up
about also strategy versus tactic
because I am highly curious on how do we
how do we create analogies between the
situation we're at with the world of
human security with fragmented tactics
compiled into strategies versus um you
know more consolidated
existing approaches. But
>> diving into awareness for a second, what
what does it actually mean to make your
organization aware into a point where
you can effectively decrease the success
rate of these attacks. So awareness is
an umbrella term. Some people want to
now call it human risk management, which
is putting lipstick on a pig in my
opinion. But awareness is about what it
should be about is changing behavior.
Changing or improving behavior. And the
goal or the change in behaviors. And
fundamentally, I'll be upfront with you.
It doesn't matter why a user does the
right thing. You just want the user to
do the right thing to reduce risk. So
for example, everybody says we should
tell the user there are bad people out
there and make and once they know there
are bad people and what's the right
thing to do they will do the right
thing. I'm like that's not really going
to work that well cuz you know there's
this whole thing of complacency. You
tell people about the evil hacker and
how often are they going to come across
an evil hacker? They don't. it becomes
this mythical being that's somehow going
to come out. On the other hand, let's
say you want users to log off their
computer at the end of the day, just as
an example, good practice. If they don't
log off their computer at the end of the
day, you say, "Hey, we're going to go
ahead and cut your computer access."
And yes, that's the stick more than the
carrot. But the issue is that people
respond more to the stick than the
carrot. And people are like, "Well,
isn't that mean?" I'm like, "Well, every
other discipline in a company uses a
stick." Like, for example, inside mo
just about every company, people have to
fill out time cards or payroll, whatever
it is. And if you don't fill out the
payroll, you don't get paid.
>> Mhm.
>> And isn't that mean that somebody just
doesn't log on the computer and do a
single task and we're not paying them?
No. It's accepted as an expectation of
business. Logging off the computer, as
an example, just one example, should be
accepted as an expectation of doing
business. And if not, you are not doing
your job properly because fundamentally
awareness should be how to do your job
properly, which includes the right
procedures. It includes for example
and I don't want to say you know verify
email to the extent you can and you
shouldn't punish people for making a
mistake. There's a difference, you know,
as the saying goes, in most cases it's
the cover up more than it's the mistake.
And as long as people don't cover things
up, like I've clicked on fishing
messages and, you know, they were pretty
clever or they caught me at the wrong
moment and I let the people know, hey, I
think you might want to go ahead and
watch for this just in case. I didn't
let it go too far,
>> but I was able to stop it. I'm like,
"Wait a second. I I entered my user ID
in something that looked legitimate, but
then it's like, wait a second, I
shouldn't have to do this." And I
stopped myself before entering the
password, as an example. And so, you
need to understand that people need to
be comfortable, but also that doing the
right thing, doing the right security
procedure should be an expected part of
their job. And if they are not doing the
right security procedures, then they
should be you know treated as somebody
who's not following policy and procedure
because if you don't enforce policy you
don't have a policy
and people need to understand that. Now
is does that count for everything in
awareness? I mean fundamentally if
somebody you know takes data out of the
company and you know like that's not a
good thing if it's not authorized and
done in the right way and that's
something somebody accidentally attaches
the wrong you know sends something to
the wrong email business email
compromise then you know that's a
mistake as long as they report it and
try to recover you can't hold them
accountable because technology should
have stopped As an example, data leak
prevention should perhaps
say, "Hey, are you really sending this
to the right group of people?" You know,
like for example, if I'm on a Gmail
thing and I invite people to a meeting
where I share a file, Gmail says, "Do
you realize you're send sharing this
with people who are not in your
organization?"
And so that's kind of a technology to
support the right thing. But anyway,
that's you know to the extent you know I
guess people need to look at the stick
as much as the carrot frankly because
while people
>> what are what are carrots what are some
potential carrots here?
>> Um example of carrots may include I mean
there's gamification
>> gamification and most people think it's
making a game. It's not making a game.
Gamification is a business principle of
rewarding people for exercising proper
behaviors, desire behaviors. So the best
example is frequent flyer programs that
I'm part of. Sales programs are example.
And what's the example in frequent flyer
programs? The more I fly the airline,
the better my rewards are.
>> That makes me want to stick with them. I
get a call, you know, I can call the
airline and not have to wait 90 minutes.
I could get somebody
You know, so there are benefits for, you
know, that's a gamification. They are
rewarding me for the desired behavior of
flying and spending money on their
airline. Likewise, sales programs are an
example of gamification. They reward
salespeople for doing for selling the
tools that they want people to sell. As
an example, in the practical world, if
you want people to take your awareness
training or you want people to report
incidents and reporting incidents, even
if you report yourself, you are rewarded
for,
you know, making a mistake. That's an
example of a good behavior cuz you need
we need people to be eyes and ears even
if it's on themselves. And I don't mean
playing big brother, but for example, I
accidentally clicked on a fishing
message. I might have left a USB drive
out in the open or something like that
and encouraging that type of behavior.
Just as an example, reporting fishing
messages, you know, even that fish
report button, even if it is a fishing
simulation, you want to reward people
for actually saying, "Hey, I think I
caught something."
>> Absolutely. If somebody reports
something, you can then take action on
it as an example.
>> Oh, absolutely. Now, I'm curious, have
you have you seen more impactful
examples of change of behavior,
successful change of behavior when it
comes to carrots versus sticks? Is there
some do you have some observations as to
what what has been more effective from a
I guess an employee behavior change
perspective?
>> No. Um honestly it's the sticks. I mean
clearly and know people in awareness oh
we're not I'm like unfortunately let me
give you an example and it was the most
clear-cut example. There was one early
in my career, well earlier in my career,
I should say, I was uh I was what the
company referred to as the mystery
shopper where I would go undercover
every six months and rob them blind.
>> And in one case, and this includes
hacking, it's not just social
engineering. And in one case, what
happened was I really hacked this one
system with all the critical data. And
so when I was there back at the company
for this one company, it was the second
time I was there. I went and like after
I, you know, raped and pillaged the
company, what happened was the CISOs
told me it's like so and so wants to
meet with you after you're done. And I'm
like, why? It's like, well, you really
screwed over his systems and he wants to
know how you did it, which is a good,
you know, you know, good thing. So
anyway, I met with the guy and the first
question was why me? I go, "This sounds
so cliche, but you have all the data."
And he's like, "I guess that's true."
And then he, you know, I tell him how
like what the what the vulnerabilities
were that I exploited at the time and so
on to make sure he fixed them all. And
then I go, "Now I have a question for
you. Why is it easier now than it was
six months ago?" And the guy's like,
"Oh, that's easy." I'm like, "Really?"
And he's like, you know what happens
when you know last time you were here
like everybody like thought, oh this is
really bad. We need to take action. The
CEO sends out a message that says cyber
security is important. Awareness is
important. He's like okay. You get a
message that says awareness is
important. I agree. Awareness is
important. Click. Then you get another
message that says donate to the United
Way. Okay. That's that's important.
Yeah, I agree. you know, stealing from
the company is bad. I agree. Stealing
from the company is bad. Then he goes,
that's pretty much what happens. You
read it, it goes away. But he goes, on
the other hand, let me show and he shows
me this piece of paper because this was
a Southern California type office
building. And all these office buildings
are like one twostory buildings. And
given it's Southern California, instead
of grass, there are all these nice
decorative rocks outside the window so
they don't have to water the grass. And
what happened was people were taking
these decorative rocks, throwing them
through windows, and then grabbing
computers and, you know, basically smash
and grabs on these computers on the
first floor of the building.
>> And what happened was this was a
problem. The physical security manager
and he shows me the message. The
physical security manager put out a
message that says, "We have had a series
of smash and grabs." As a result of
these smash and grabs, what's going to
happen is if you have a window office,
at the end of every day, you're to put
your shades down, turn your lights off,
and lock your door. Your manager is
responsible for verifying that at the
end of the day, your shades are down,
the lights are off, your door is locked.
Our guards will do rounds to ensure the
shades are down, you know, lights are
off, you know, doors are locked. On the
first example, your manager will talk to
you. On the second example, where
there's a violation, you know, security
will talk to you. On the third example,
you may be fired. And they didn't say
fire, they say you may be your
employment may be terminated. And smash
and grabs went completely away.
Why? because everybody was putting their
shades down, turning their lights off.
The bad guys didn't know whether or not
there were computers in the room or
whatever, and so on. And so the stick
worked, if that makes any sense at all.
>> Absolutely. So
>> because people knew exactly what to do.
They knew the problem. Sorry, my dog
wants to join the while he just wants to
be pet while this is going on.
>> They're a part of this. This is great.
[laughter]
My uh the so the the moral of the story
is what happened the physical as opposed
to the CEO topdown saying cyber security
and security awareness are critical. The
physical security manager just said hey
I don't need the CEO I just need to go
ahead and say here's the problem. Here's
your expected action and here are the
repercussions for not taking it because
smash and grabs are bad. I stole more
data six months before. Sorry about
this, but I
>> No, this is great. This is exactly what
the story is about.
>> Absolutely.
>> He and and it was perceived as less
important than a couple of computers
being stolen
and but again everything was clear on
what was to happen and we didn't do that
with these security awareness.
>> Yes.
>> That's my example. So if we're looking a
little bit
more broadly into the way that security
awareness intersects with um intersects
with you know the different solutions to
orchestrate a strategy. Where are we at
do you think in the industry of the
world of human security today December
2024? How do you see the mapping of the
space? Where do you see are there more
you know are we stronger in weaker in
I see that we have a lot of good
technologies
on prevention detection and you know
response that are not looked at
holistically.
I see we have awareness which frankly
has come down to implementing random
tools. innovation is like okay maybe
getting better data out of those
security awareness tools
>> in that space but you know I don't see
us as addressing it like I think we
should as a strategy where we need to go
ahead and look at how do these tools
like mapping out for example what has to
happen for a user to
lose a laptop what has to happen for a
user to click on a fishing message and
create damage. And so, for example, I'll
go back to the because fishing's easy.
Everybody knows fishing, you know, we
need to filter out the messages as best
we can. We need to go ahead give
awareness, but we also need to give
nudges.
We need to give warnings like go ahead
and have double checks like McAfei site
advisor. How many people remember that?
But that would go ahead and warn people,
hey, this is not a good website and
stuff. We need those warnings back in
more frequently. Then we need to go
ahead and say, hey, you don't have
permission to download software and
stuff like that. With the case of lost
laptops, yes, you need to go ahead and
have go what was it? Lowjack or
something. I don't know like phone like
at least you know um iPhone phone home
type of technology seems to be
available. We need like so for example
laptops should have their hard drives
encrypted you know should have um the
computers locked by default as an
example so if somebody does lose a
laptop at least the amount of compromise
of the data or whatever else is going to
be minimized. Not to say it's going to
be perfect cuz you have somebody really
advanced might be able to crack the
encryption on the hard drive but still
you're taking steps and figuring out
okay what can we do to perhaps better
secure it? But what can we do to track
the equipment? What can we do assuming
it is ever compromised? How to find it?
How to get it home? How to make sure
it's useless if it is stolen or whatever
the case may be. And yes, a user should
be aware. Do not lose your laptop. But
at the same time, these things happen,
you know, and I'm just using that as an
example. Map out how does this come to
be? How are the damages or how are the
losses incurred? And how can we stop it
from start to finish with a holistic
approach under the assumption that every
point in that whole approach is going to
fail at some point?
>> Absolutely. So, so Ira to new
entrepreneurs in this space who are
looking at the world of human
vulnerabilities or human zero days, what
would be your best recommendations for
them?
So if I were going to look at this, I
would look at
So if if I was an entrepreneur, I would
want to look at, okay, from start to
finish,
where are the I don't want to call it
the weak links, but where are the
vulnerabilities that need to be patched?
Because there's no such thing, you know,
I mean, there's stronger there's
stronger and weaker links. There's no
such thing as a weakest link
>> in order for like the user is the
weakest link. The user is not the
weakest link. The people letting the
user be the weakest link are the weakest
link.
>> Um but you need to go ahead and say what
technologies might go ahead and stop
this better or mo and these days what
would limit the amount of loss that
could be occur that could be incurred
should something happen. If you have
ways of putting in good nudges along the
way, that's, you know, that's something
that could be attractive as well, like
you know, better marking of data, better
flagging of messages, you know, perhaps
intervening when bad things can h when
bad things are triggered, you know, just
as a few examples.
>> Abs. Absolutely. So, I Ira to to wrap up
what I what I really enjoy is an amazing
conversation. Mhm.
>> Tell me a little bit about what you
really love about the space or cyber
security in general. I mean, you've been
at this for a while and you seem like a
guy who who does what he enjoys. So, so
why why this? You know, what what's
what's been keeping you on your toes?
So, um yeah, hold on a second. Uh uh
let's see. So, what keeps me on my toes?
Um
frankly, I don't know if anything keeps
me on my toes. There's like the old
saying, you know, are you going to lose
sleep at night or something like that.
I'm like, you shouldn't lose sleep at
night as a seesaw because fundamentally
a cyber security program is like a ship.
It's going to be offc course 99% of the
time and you should have processes in
place that are constantly dealing with
those problems, focusing where to go.
It's a continual process to keep things
aimed in the right direction. That's
number one. And I was actually just
thinking this. I unfortunately had a
family medical emergency like a couple
weeks ago.
>> Mhm.
>> And I was thinking, gee, I should have
really gone to med school. It would have
been so much more valuable. And then I
started to think, you know what, without
cyber security these days, these
hospitals are bricked,
you know? And
that's a little bit of a good feel that
somehow hopefully what I've been able to
do is while I'm not the doctor, I'm able
to help doctors or whoever else be
infinitely more effective and enable
them to do their job because I look at
security as an enabler. Like a lot of
security people I call losers because
they think, "Oh gee, I'm an expense. You
know, I'm an afterthought in all this."
I'm like you need to as a cyber security
professional your attitude should be I
am an enabler without cyber security you
know I mean I I'll use you know my past
employer Walmart without cyber security
the supply chain would crumble without
cyber security e-commerce would crumble
you couldn't take payments and
everything like that cyber security is
critical for the fortune one company to
stay up and running and frankly it's
critical for every company out there to
stay up and running these days. You
know, you have these small companies you
never heard of go out of business
because of a ransomware incident. So,
we're unfortunately
enabling things that we shouldn't have
to do, but it's still critical to do it.
>> Yeah. Ira, thank you so much for joining
me today. This was such an awesome
conversation. And I I I loved your
perspective on know on on not just human
security but largerly speaking on on
tactics and strategy in the context of
cyber security which is not where I
expected us to go but it was fascinating
and uh and obviously speaking from a
wealth of experience. So I I really want
to thank you so much for taking the time
to be here and for joining me. Thank
you.
>> Okay. No thank you. I appreciate it.
>> Thank you.